we're gonna watch the trailer for 600
ground I am doing a joker voice I'm not
doing a ride just take it out of your
nose a little bit just a little more
normal I don't you do it John I can't do
it I'm not writing good don't guide me
if you can't go the path yourself okay
then we shouldn't do this trailer
reaction we shouldn't do any Matthew
verse 21
all right we're going underground
trailer starring Ryan Reynolds
at the official title Michael Bay
directed Netflix vehicle all the money
in the world must been thrown into this
before we go into this trailer reaction
people thank you to everyone who has
joined us on our patreon page and has
made it a successful month and
successful year for us over there we do
weekly q and A's as well as TV show
reactions stream along sync up watch
along with us those shows are Cobra Kai
season 2 haunting of Hill House season 1
Gotham made it to season 3 stranger
thing season 3 agents of shield and
there are several shows where we have
the option to stream along or have
reaction highlights included and those
shows are attack on tight and Full Metal
Alchemist Brotherhood my hero academia
movie included as well Death Note Code
Geass one pouch man Hunter hunter super
natural and he does music video coverage
weekly come join us on our patreon page
to die
the Dark Knight smokin aces care
okay
[Music]
well if I told you I know what happens
when you die you become a ghost
doing more criminal records that's part
of being dead is this freedom
[Music]
no policies or politics no one answer to
no one
[Music]
you take out and truly evil people
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
Wow I am digging this Oh God data
skyscrapers evening
[Music]
awesome possum I really enjoyed that
trailer that was so cool I cannot wait
to watch that movie on this device right
all Michael Bay films especially should
be seen by my headphones on go wow that
is crazy look at the detail you had a
comment we were watching of how this
trailer should have ended earlier I
disagree because everyone knows that a
Michael Bay movie is always best in
trailer format the trailers are usually
better than the movies themselves yes so
I'm very sufferable along exactly
give me another trailer because those
are the best way to experience Michael
Bay movies that being said though this
to me just looks like a really really
good time this looks like a total blast
pure Michael Bay isn't it looks like
Michael Bay's spliced with some Mission
Impossible spy movie kind of genre
blending because the start offer you're
like okay this is just a little bit
larger than life hide in action and then
it got like totally sci-fi by the end
with the magnets and stuff but I was
eating this trailer oh man I feel like
the type of humor that Ryan Reynolds
brings his sensibilities with the kind
of action comedies and Michael Bay makes
that kind of blend just seems like it
would work pretty well yeah one is Rhett
Reese and Paul Wernick that's kind of
their brand of writing they do these
edgy action-oriented comedic sort of
things you know yeah and it's got all
the Michael Bay isms
desert looks it's got the glossiness
it's got its Dutch angles here and there
it really I watched a great video essay
on the Patrick Age Willems channel and
like literally everything he brings up
practically is in this video about
Michael Bay's style as a director and
there's certainly a lot of CG in this
trailer P does kind of look like he's
leveling up to that Mission Impossible
like no we're gonna do some really huge
stunts if we're gonna play him as in
camera as possible and to be fair for as
much CG as Michael Bay does use he does
use a lot of practical stuff to make
that CG look good well yeah a lot of the
stunts here look like real human me
yes stuntmen but they probably had CGI
enhancements in the backgrounds and
stuff but for the most part no no that
people even on the magnet sequence when
they were all flying up against the
walls and stuff those look like real
performers who were being thrown against
the wall
I feel like for as much crap as he gets
that is one credit you can give him as
he does know to put as much in camera
typically as possible or yeah with the
actors and with any physical elements
that need to explode that we can get you
know in camera and the other thing too
about Michael Bay is I've said this for
a long time and I feel like it is true
that really the quality of a Bay film
just depends on who's writing it because
I think he can turn a good script into a
good movie it just takes the right
script and this looks like the kind of
script that could potentially not be
obnoxious but really play into his
strengths as a director yeah I mean now
I like Michael Bay movies I like Michael
Bay movies
I just don't like the Transformers
franchise which I know is essentially
his French eyes other than bumblebee of
course yeah I don't like any of those
movies but you name another Michael Bay
movie and I even though like a low score
brought in Tomatoes I'm like I actually
really enjoy the island like the war
movie he did with John Krasinski pain
and gain experiences bad boys movies I
really enjoy those too like I think
Michael Bay's a a really fun action
comedy director do his movies usually
overstay their welcome sure I know what
I'm walking into when I see this term
I'm like yeah this is the Michael Bay I
love yeah yeah I just can't stand his
transformers the only thing I don't like
him from this is like he's getting out
there having fun again doing what he
loves to do by all accounts I mean from
everything other filmmakers have
commented on it seems to be that he is
right at home just making a huge thing
collide so I find it funny how the
marketing for this is really pushing
Ryan Reynolds even the title of the
Netflix video is starring Ryan Reynolds
but there's not little there's lack of
mention that this is a Michael Bay movie
for some reason Reynolds has a better
social clout yeah yeah he does it looks
great in the movie you know I liked when
he has a beard because that's when you
know he's not playing Deadpool that's
and you could take him a little more
seriously
yeah but it's like slightly less jokey
Ryan Reynolds like joking but but still
kind of more straightforward badass Ryan
Reynolds well I yeah I mean I would like
him to branch out a little bit more with
the roles because what really hooked me
and Ryan Reynolds was the movie buried
like I liked his comedies beforehand
like Van Wilder I love the movie just
friends I think that's a hilarious film
but buried was like wow this guy could
really freaking act even Amityville
Horror remake which I know gets a lot of
flack I thought he did a really good job
in the movie so you know seeing a role
like this which can splice a little bit
more of that intense like there a moment
serum like that looks straight out of
smoking aces and like the way that I am
no like the gliadin seriously it's like
it's dramatic because when he has a beer
today yeah even the serious part of
detective Pikachu with him oh my bad
yellow he's covered in hair yeah that's
what it is Pikachu exactly no exactly
that's technically what I heard right on
this part I just connects to everything
else Oh either Michael Bay thing plenty
of hot girls yeah yeah yeah are the
leads which is I'm interested to see how
that works out and like an ensemble
environment where theoretically they're
equal parts of the team you know it's
like is the camera gonna Google Ryan
Reynolds package the same way like when
that girl in the green dress I don't
know the actor's name off the top of my
head when she got out of the car I was
like okay it's like a model shot and
then it showed her face I was like no
she's on the main cast I wonder how this
film is gonna photograph its people but
doesn't matter what matters is everyone
looks sexy and that's true yes sure
everybody looks sexy that's how he
frames his movies oh yeah and every
can't every shot is the money shot all
right guys well are you excited for six
underground we even talked about the
plot they're vigilantes baron
yeah and they both ought to be dead
there's six of them it's like how low
you're supposed to bury someone play on
words ha ha very unique guys lovely you
can subscribe to the real rejects click
that notification bell you can check us
on patreon where we got all those
goodies we talked about the beginning of
this video
salute